turning to the Border crisis more
migrant buses arriving in New York City
this morning all this as Texas governor
Greg Abbott is calling out New York city
mayor Eric Adams for the NYPD pulling
over and ticketing some of those migrant
buses sent from The Lone Star State yeah
the governor's office telling Fox News
this is another pathetic Ploy by mayor
Adams to stop Texas from busting
migrants to his self-declared Sanctuary
City each bus used by the state of Texas
for this busing Mission undergoes
through Texas Department of Public
Safety commercial vehicle inspection
before departing for Sanctuary cities
joining us live is Fox News contributor
Lara Trump Laura so the New York Post is
reporting that that members of the NYPD
spent hours meticulously searching each
bus for any possible infraction
including booking logs tread tires fuel
levels even windshield wiper placement
and these are the buses that of course
are pulling into Port Authority and
dropping the migrants off the goal is to
get these buses off the road so that the
migrants stop coming do you think it's
going to work
well Carly it's a good thing there's not
a crime crisis going on in New York City
await there is and this is where the
NYPD is focusing their time but yes it
turns out that whenever you violate the
laws on the southern border and you
allow that to happen it is a problem all
across the country ask the people down
in Texas how it's been for them it is
amazing to see these Sanctuary cities
and Sanctuary areas as they so proudly
proclaimed not too long ago realize very
quickly that whenever they are actually
faced with an influx of people coming in
they can't deal with it that is the
reason by the way we have the laws we
have in place at our Southern border but
no do I think that this is going to
deter anything Carly absolutely not it
is pretty outrageous though to see Eric
Adams mayor of New York City and ex-cop
employee tactics like this this looks
like you know targeting enforcement of
laws which you really can't do knew if
he has a grievance with what is going on
and the influx of illegal immigrants
coming to his area and into our country
he can Target 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
because it is the policies of Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris the borders are that
have led us down this path it is
unsustainable amazing to see these
Sanctuary cities finally take you
mentioned Kamala there Lara as we look
live on our screen we just saw a live
latest Bus arrival here's the vice
president last night on Seth Meyers
listen
I just think it's an absolute
dereliction of Duty if you see a problem
and if we agree that that we need to
address it then if you're a leader
participate in a solution
right when we first came in office the
first bill that we proposed was for a
pathway for citizenship was to fix a
broken immigration system which was
broken under the previous administration
participate in the solution because we
are offering Solutions but instead this
gamesmanship
with real human beings who trust us I
need a 10 second answer my friend if you
are a leader aren't you the borders are
Kamala
yes a dereliction of Duty says the
borders are who has been down to the
Border once was in Texas last week did
not bother to go down there give us all
a break we know who's causing this they
know it's a green lit situation every
single person coming over the southern
border thanks to Kamala Harris and Joe
Biden Lara Trump thank you thank you
Carly ship because thanks to all of you
fox and friends now I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis